in order to reach across the aisle in
order to try to grab some of those
moderate some of those suburban
housewives
they had a handful of squishy
republicans
some of whom most of whom no one even
remembers
and they came out to endorse at the dnc
because you got to ask yourself has
trump lost any votes trump
won in 2016 no one thought he was going
to win and a lot of people were
skeptical of him then he's done a great
job since then he's assuaged a lot of
fears the never
never trump movement has completely
collapsed so
who do you lose what people are saying
is it's the suburban housewives
so you want to appeal to these more
middle-of-the-road republicans
did the democrats succeed at that let's
take a listen first up meg whitman
former ceo of hp who ran unsuccessfully
for some political offices
a woman that basically nobody remembers
at this point
here is meg whitman's message to the
convention
i'm meg whitman i'm a longtime
republican and a long-time ceo
and let me tell you donald trump has no
clue how to run a business
let alone an economy okay if donald
trump has no clue how to run a business
or an economy
how come we've all heard of him we all
know him he's the most powerful man in
the world
and very few people remember you
if he last time i checked the trump
organization
is doing better these days is much more
prominent in the public imagination
than hewlett-packard that you the
company you used to run
and i think she runs another one i don't
even know the name of this company that
she currently runs
she's a lifelong republican what are her
positions i just did a quick little
google search
she's a lifelong staunch republican
who's in favor of open borders
who's against marriage and who's
pro-abortion
that's it they got us wow principled
conservatism
oh my god donald trump he's a fake
conservative not like the real
conservatives like
open borders anti-marriage pro-abortion
meg whitman right how about the next one
another whitman coincidentally
christine todd whitman former governor
of new jersey a thousand years ago
here is christine todd whitman's
invective against president trump i'm
governor christine todd whitman
what am i doing here i'm a lifelong
republican
my parents were introduced at a
republican national convention by their
parents that's how far back it goes
but this isn't about a republican or
democrat it's about a person
a person decent enough stable enough
strong enough to get our economy back on
track a person who can work with
everyone
democrats and republicans to get things
done
donald trump isn't that person joe biden
is
joe biden as principled conservative
i've been a republican so long my
grandparents were
republicans and they introduced my my
parents who are republicans and
okay let's take a look at her record oh
yeah against marriage pro-abortion
and pro-partial birth abortion this
monster this this woman
supports a policy that would allow you
to
partially give birth and then kill the
infant
in 1999 whitman when she was when she
was governor
vetoed a bill that outlawed partial
birth abortion
that's that rock-ribbed conservative so
if you're a republican who's going to
vote for joe biden
you're siding with those principled
conservatives like the ones who support
partial birth abortion and then then my
favorite
then the best we had been waiting we
knew this moment was going to come
john kasich junk whose father was a
mailman if in case you had forgotten
john kasich
comes out he was a somewhat prominent
2016 contender for president on the
republican side
he endorses joe biden because america
is at a crossroads take a listen america
is at a crossroads
sometimes elections represent a real
choice a choice we make as individuals
and as a nation about which path we want
to take when we've come to challenging
times
america is at that crossroads today
he's standing at a crossroads
you still don't no this is so lame
this is somehow even lamer than john
kasich if you just took john kasich by
himself that would be very lame
but john kasich referring to crossroads
while standing at a crossroad
that is like the lamest thing i've ever
seen i was waiting for him to say
america's come to a fork in the road and
then he lifts up a
dining fork or he just got there and he
just started
he just started turning himself around
like spinning around america is at a
turning point
you know it's not not very convincing
and what is he talking about
you know i'm not going to subject you to
listening to the rest of his ridiculous
oration but none of these people ever
get to issues
all it boils down to is donald trump was
mean to me
and joe biden was nice to me and it's
all about me
me me it's all about personal behavior
and it's all about the tweets
because for these people even kasich
kasich is the worst one because kasich
actually had a pretty good record
in his early political career but
somewhere along the way he got to
get to a fork in the road and he took he
took the wrong path
you know what happens at crossroads by
the way i don't know if any of you are
blues
music aficionados bad things happen at
crossroads
you know people meet that people tend to
meet the devil at crossroads okay
and that would that would seem to be
what's happening here
because for these people i mean maybe
john kasich used to be about something
real certainly hasn't been in quite a
long time
politics is not about changing anything
politics is not about
supporting our cherished institutions
politics is not about rolling back
this awful tide of leftism it's not
about pushing back against
this anti-constitutional administrative
bureaucracy that's taking our political
power away from
we the people it's just about
going along to get along it's just about
being
the governor being the congressman being
the president it's not about doing
anything
there are some people who have the
audacity to refer to themselves as
principled conservatives
who are siding with these hacks because
they say trump's not a real conservative
trump is the most conservative
politician of my lifetime
not in any traditional you know not not
in any you know past 30 40 years since
not in his comportment even in many ways
but in what he's doing in his political
vision
much more conservative than any of these
hacks
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts